[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about everything we know about the
third episode of season 8 the battle for
NFL supported with trailers teasers
previews and a few leaked photos at the
end of episode 2 the army of the Dead
arrives of NFL the living is as ready as
they can be for the battle against the
knockings army they made as much weapons
out of journalist as they could and
pretty much all defences are made out of
journalist as well from Manta cavalry to
anti clamping the fences and walls main
portion of the link army star outside
banner fell from the Trekkie to the
unsullied then the Knights of the Vale
libri and Podrick and Shara waiting for
the knight king's army to attack we
already knew that the big battle for me
NFL is set to take place in season 8 and
it's been confirmed to take place in the
third episode of the final season by an
actor who plays the night King Latimer
Furtick even though NFL was not the
first castle to get destroyed on his way
south the 19 filing arrived and the next
thing we'll see is an epic battle for
venom fell further declare the new slip
during a fan convention in Hungary it's
an inspiring third episode of the last
season there's a battle that creator's
intended to be a historic moment in
television almost the full episode will
be about a battle it'll take about one
hour thirty states they filmed this
battle for three months in the wind and
rain outdoors and then for another month
in a huge studio which makes this far
and away the most labor-intensive battle
sequence in the show's history and
therefore in the history of TV Herenton
vehicles cover story from a few months
back gave us an inside look into the
final game interim season through the
eyes of james Gilbert it's shaping up to
be what probably almost certainly is the
longest consecutive battle sequence in
cinema history
to film the Battle of Winterfell HBO
built an enormous green screen in order
to bring their vision of an epic battle
to life so close gathered there for this
week's long shoot first to get the
unsullied and yell solid they're not the
only people from Essos who are part of
the battle of interval there are also
the Trekkie writers they'll sell it for
failings formation they're famous battle
tactic large group of them fighting in
lockstep falen says using spear and
shield which is jealous on it as well as
we all know journalists also known as
is the key to killing the nine king's
army as along with Valyrian steel it's
one of the two known substances capable
of killing both White Walkers and their
whites the living will use hearing lists
in pretty much every way possible with
this formation they once defeated an
army there was approximately seven times
bigger numbers let's hope they're still
as good here above the unsullied in top
left corner you can see two gems in sky
it's regal and Giovanni and no them are
johnandannie
they will fly out to the near heel to
overlook the battlements and wait for
the night king to come from rain rain is
the 19th target and as you learned from
the war council meeting the plan is to
wait for the night King to show up at
the godswood ceiling we'll be protecting
brain and from the preview we can tell
there will be a lot of action going on
Brens line from the trailer everything
you did brought you earlier now where
you belong home it's probably the theme
before the battle takes place even John
at some point will fight in the guard
suit later on did the track Indian solid
it'll be in the metal while the
northerners and the Knights of the Vale
will be protecting flanks Brienne is
commanding left flank besides her Jaime
and combined forces of the Knights of
the Vale in openers
how do I know they're on the left flank
we know it from the war council meeting
that the combined forces of the
northerners and the Knights of the Vale
are protecting left flank and also
there's a bunch of Chevy shades that was
to be on the walls of NFL signalizing
utters when is the right time to light
the trench and he'll probably take
command of the archers on the walls as
well from leaked photos we know that
multiple people will build flaming
swords in the battle against the dead
out of all the characters we know
barrack no Darian is one of the most
closely associated with the flaming
sword and he is the one VC building it
in the trailer seems like no Darian
shared a trait with a few people next to
barrack we see the Hound in the midst of
a battle for Vener fell against White
Walkers
barrack is ready but the Hound is
terrified and in fear of all the fire
around him better fel is on fire there
flaming swords around him and probably
flaming arrows flying all around however
I also think there's going to be a
moment the handle finally defeat his
fear of fire and actually be of some
help for the Sharks the good news about
this battle is that will finally see
much more of dermals that's right not
only goes but probably of Nymeria as
well ghost will have a fair amount of
screen time and almost definitely fight
this battle or you'll see McGann power
told The Huffington Post he has a fair
amount of screen time in season eight he
does show up as a matter of fact I think
we'll ready so goes the official trailer
although many people disagreed it's
actually him in the background anyways
the night king is coming
but winner fell and the living will be
ready when I fell now has a dug trench
all around it and everyone will - dragon
with weapons and shields the battle for
Winterfell will without a doubt be the
greatest battle sequence in the
television history
this battle is directed by Miguel
suppose Nick the guy behind some of the
best episodes of Game of Thrones like
hardhome vensim enter and battle the
bastards talking about this huge battle
form NFL it's brutal said star peter
dinklage tyrion lanister it makes the
battle the bastards look like a theme
park writing earlier about this historic
sequence James Hebert called it
wall-to-wall action and detail how it
jumps between the stories of several
different characters
everyone wants know what happens who
wins who dies and right of the bat I
have to bring you the bad news
everything we have from deserts to
leaked photos point to Messi defeat for
living winter will not fall at
Winterfell
this was teased by Rafael teaser in
which we see Starks ancestral home in
ruins and abandoned with an alkene
entering through its gates this battle
will be a huge defeat for the living
from the photos we can tell when our
fellows on fire the night king has won
there's a possibility that the night
king uses some kind of magic or even
he's done that Jerome is Aryan to burn
down NFL but I actually think it's the
living who burns it down if their own
purpose story catches on fire by itself
from all the fire they used to kill
White's if it's a purpose then I can
definitely see John using Ragle to burn
down Winterfell after they're forced to
retreat why would John burn down his
home well if they lost it means there's
tens of thousands corpses laying inside
and outside Winterfell you know what
happens to those who died they become
part of the night Kings armies and the
living cannot allow those numbers to get
any higher so after they lose most of
their armies the living will probably
make a decision to retreat and run and
they're going to have to burn Winterfell
to make sure the army of the Dead does
bro this is foreshadowed by Edvin he
told to John and Sam Lessman let's burn
the rest of us I believe the crypts of
NFL will play a huge role during this
fight and it's going to help Peter to
living or the dead tremendously in case
you don't know there hidden passageways
built so the Lords of Winterfell could
escape in emergency a mr. Lewin actually
offered Theon to use it to escape winter
fell and join the Nights Watch man
Ramsay came if the living are the ones
who will use that then they will use it
to escape after defeat but if it's not
king who uses it then he will use it to
attack when I'm felt from inside while
at the same time attacking from outside
if the night King uses it then it would
also confirm a popular theory of him
being a stark because remember those
hidden passages were built for the stark
Lords and if he was a start then he
knows the body's secret passage I
believe we have already seen this hidden
passage in the crypts of NFL teaser for
season 8 Ferrari is passing through some
tunnel and I believe the night King will
use a to attack when I fell from the
inside in episode 2 it was mentioned way
too many times other crypts are the
safest place to be
gantry sedative Aria Gillis today to
those ladies it was mentioned on the war
council multiple times John said it was
same juris sedative Liana they're
totally not going to be safe down there
some theory is the night King will raise
the dead in the crypts but I believe the
night King will actually come from the
crypts as you might expect this battle
will leave many dead check out this
image of lifeless bodies strewn across
the ground outside of NFL's settimana
glass we can see what looks like a feel
strong bodies to the left of the castle
including some that look like horses as
it mana glass the ground that Mangrum on
quarry was littered with bodies unlike a
mani glass someone was able to get up
close and personal with the bodies there
all kinds of corpses set maker moon
quarry from Myron forest whites in this
stays the miss frost the direwolf marker
as well as the marker for Denison solid
forces but unfortunately denotes an army
in the unsullied are not going to be the
only casualties for the living it's
confirmed that most of the track you
will fall as well and they're surely
after be brought back to live by the
white walkers to act as their minions
here you can see the tricky whites
riding on horseback
after this epic battle when I felt
national Concord North in the living or
least what's left of them we'll have to
retreat south and win over exactly one
of the teasers provided this shot of
standing in front of a fireplace better
back turn to John and the details on
that fireplace confirmed there at
Dragonstone take a look at all the
details on the shot from the fireplace
itself to its props the stone curves and
the metalwork it's the very same thing
we already saw a chicken stone so now we
know they will retreat that jorgan stone
in Episode four after Winterfell falls
to the night king in Episode three
anyways we'll talk more about it in the
upcoming videos there's plenty of battle
stuff we got from Malta promotional
material for season eight episode three
ferritic said and at the same time
spoiled another stare down between Jon
Snow and the night king that is set to
take place in season eight perhaps this
time it will be more personal maybe this
time it's not just some violins the
night King raises from dead but it's
actually his own family members from the
crypts like for example recently
deceased Rickon stark from the official
trailer we can tell for sure the target
Jon will be fighting fiercely for their
home and something likely the dead
Starks resurrected by the night king
from the crypts will chase Arya to the
host of NFL but let's get a bit back and
see how could have already got herself
in this situation so what happens is the
Jaime probably see a bunch of whites
breaching the crypts of NFL or the
godswood of NFL wherever brain is at
that moment Jamie sees it and so he
shouts brain to someone likely to Arya
as a warning that her brother's life is
in danger then Jaime an area probably
run to defend brain so Jamie and Arya go
for bran who is probably accompanied by
Sam and this right here might be Arya
and behind her Jamie and Sam pushing
brain as they all run for something so
Jamie and Sam her pushing Brandon's
wheelchair will not be as quick as Arya
she'll try and distract at something
from them running the other way and that
way is saving brain and this is a clip
of her doing it and here we can actually
see what's chasing her in this lightened
version if you look closely you can
notice that she looks to be pursued by
something with a skeletal face
judging by the scared look of Arya I
have the feeling that she's running from
something that came from me inside the
crypts the dead Starks keep in mind that
Arya does not fear death she'd stand and
fight anyone or anything
Arya would not be afraid of whites or
white walkers as she's actually fighting
those in the trailer she would not run
from them especially since she's holding
a knife made rather jealous which kills
them I think the one chasing her or
least one among them is
her brother akin who died at the barrel
the bastard Samos buried in the crypts
below of NFL Aria season at Rican chic
ricin is not able to fight him so she
runs all I hope and expect to see in
this battle for when FL is joining Aria
fight alongside their Darryl's ghost in
Ameria and the dire wolves don't
actually end up sacrificing themselves
for their masters although they most
likely will as I said earlier ghost is
already confirmed to fight in this
battle but his sister Namira is as
likely to reappear and fight as well the
media will probably also reappear with a
pack of wolves during this battle
joining the fight for Winterfell and
helper brother ghost an area defended
arias Darville briefly showed up in
season 7 but in my opinion a mere
ischemia was just setting the stage for
something bigger much much bigger in the
books author george RR martin keeps the
mystic named Mirri and her wolf pack
very much on the minds of readers via
are your dreams and the news of a vest
pack led by an Amira taking stark
enemies deep in freight territory in a
2014 interview with Mashable Monty is
named as important role in the final two
books you know I don't like to give
things away
he told with a grain but Martin added
you don't hang a giant wolf pack on the
wall unless you intend to use it that
pretty much says it all by itself Nomura
and her pack of wolves will appear in
the darkest hour arrived out of nowhere
to try to turn the tide wouldn't it be
nice if ghosts also got to fight by his
wolf sister side just as John will fight
alongside Arya
Jenny song sang by Podrick in episode 2
was farewell to so many characters who
will die in this battle
well many will die but out of the main
characters prolly Podrick because he's
got too much screen time in episode
juror moment a few north North's
probably Edinburgh Caswell and possibly
theme great while trying to save some of
the stars films whole story seems to be
going this way and it does seem like
something he do for his dark siblings
thean will most likely die in this
episode he saved his sister he came back
to venom fell to defend his home in the
Starks he fully redeemed himself
we know from teasers that John Inari
will definitely not die as I see John
Mead an eternal stone where they will
retreat after this defeat and Maisie
Williams teased us about her character
which confirms she is not going to die
Maisie said this about Aria there's this
platelet area between trying to
who she wants to be getting back to back
to that naivete and innocence with her
family and her unfinished business what
this means is that Arya will stick with
her family and fight for Winterfell
against the night king in Episode three
but Reverend fell false and manorial
learns of sources yet another betrayal
over her family she'll have to say a
temporary goodbye to her family and go
to finish her infamous list I will go on
her mission and she will likely be
accompanied by the Hound there's a high
possibility that Arya will trail to
King's Landing to put an end to Cersei
or at least to try as The Fighter starts
I don't think sensor brain will die
Jaime nari will say brain and all three
will likely survive someone might
sacrifice his or hers life to save Sansa
with the most likely candidates being
Theon and Brienne long story short Arya
and Jon are confirmed not to die but
it's also safe to say that none of the
Starks are going to die in this battle
for their home episode three will end
exactly how I expect with a living
retreating south okay guys there will be
everything we know about the season
eight episode three supported with all
the trailers teasers previews and the
few spoilers how do you like the third
episode of the final season which is
probably going to be the best episode in
Game of Thrones and what do you think
will also take place please make sure to
let me know in the comment section down
below and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace